vsauce kevin here with 64 kittens two
wallets one coin and some math that lies
to you some of you are going to be okay
with that because you'll already have
found cognitive shelter in the unknown
others won't even see it
i've made a lot of videos about
different probability problems and
paradoxes russian roulette monty hall
the birthday paradox and
we've solved them all but what happens
when the math is right and there's still
a paradox what happens when you know a
right answer is
actually wrong
wallets
imagine i choose two people randomly as
they walk on the streets of manhattan i
give them the option to play a game they
compare the amount of money in their
wallets and the person with the lower
amount wins all the money in the other
wallet so
does either person have an advantage the
math says no
you say
yes
but wallets can wait let's start with
coin flips the probability of which is
perfectly quantifiable i've got a coin
with yes on one side and no on the other
the odds of getting a yes or no are 50
50 other than the 1 in 5 000 chance that
it lands on its edge so
50 50. the odds of getting yes no yes no
yes are 0.5 raised to the power of 5 or
0.5 times 0.5 times 0.5 times 0.5 times
0.5 equals
0.03125 cool the odds of getting 5 yeses
or 5 no's in a row well now
that's also 0.5 raised to the power of
5. every combination of yes and no has
exactly the same chance of occurring but
you know deep down that getting five in
a row doesn't happen nearly as often as
a mix of the two
how can two things have the exact same
probability of occurring yet occur
less often
i can explain with kittens real quick
this vsauce video is sponsored by vsauce
the brand new curiosity box by vsauce
will give your body a shirt your hands a
puzzle your eyeballs illusions your
bacteria a kit your brain a book and
curiosity curriculum cards detailing the
science and activities behind it all so
subscribe now to the vsauce curiosity
box and let vsauce into
your home
[Music]
you have a litter of kittens
or your
cat does let's say the cat has four
kittens and there's a 50-50 chance of
each kitten being a boy or a girl every
combination of kittens is 0.5 raised to
the power of 4 or .0625
but the most common combination isn't
the equal split of two boys two girls
you'd expect it's actually three of one
and one of the other when you map out
all the possible combinations of kittens
there are 16 combinations that all have
the same exact probability of happening
but getting a perfectly even two of each
happens in just six of the 16 combos or
37.5 percent a 3-1 split happens in 8 of
the 16 combinations
50 percent of the time you'll get 3 and
1 despite the 50-50 mass telling you
everything's got the same chance
simple math tells you one thing but
combinatorics using that math tells you
another
okay
let's get back to wallets do you have an
advantage in this game if your wallet
has less money in it you'll always win
more than that amount by taking the
other wallet that has more money in it
if your wallet has more money you'll
only lose what you've got
since the game is totally random and
neither player knows anything about the
other the probability of each player
winning and losing is the same
but when you win you'll get more money
than you lose when you don't win
so you've got a major advantage in this
game but when the other player loses
they're only losing what's in their
wallet and when they win they're winning
more than what's in their wallet they've
got a major advantage in this game
the question is how can two players
competing against each other both have
an advantage here's how they can't if
there are two outcomes x and y we can
assign probabilities to each and adding
those probabilities together has to add
up to 1. having an advantage would mean
a probability greater than 0.5 if x and
y are both greater than 0.5 you're going
to get more than one when you add them
and that's probabilistically impossible
it'd be like betting on a sports game
where vegas says both teams are favored
to win
it makes
no sense
and look maurice kreichick's payoff
matrix for the wallet game shows that
the two players have exactly the same
probabilities of winning it really is 50
50 and the math
proves it but the logic of each player
is flawless it's unassailable neither
player can have an advantage but both
players have perfectly reasonable logic
suggesting each one does have an
advantage
the problem here is that you
need to know and discarding information
makes it easier i'll talk more about
this in a future video but think how
much easier this problem gets when you
just trust the math or go with logic and
your gut
reducing a complex scenario between math
and reality lets you eliminate the
paradox and proceed comfortably but when
faced with explaining the faulty logic
of these two wallets some of the
greatest math minds could only proceed
comfortably knowing that they couldn't
really tell ya krejcic first proposed
the problem in 1944 and the two
envelopes paradox was conceived as a
derivative of it in 1953.
nearly 80 years later we don't have a
clear answer to why the math works and
the reality
doesn't
you can factor in discrete distributions
random variables or continuous density
functions to get deep into the math but
the truth is that
probability tells you one thing
and logic tells you
another the moment we know something
about the players in the wallet game we
enter the territory of subjectivistic
interpretation of probability the
bayesian notion of utilizing information
about a problem to assign possible
values to different frequencies of
outcome so like if one player is 18
years old you might think they're less
likely to have a lot of money in their
wallet because younger people are more
likely to earn less carry cards or pay
with their phones if a player is older
and on vacation in manhattan their
wallet might be more likely to be loaded
with cash but in our wallet game
we don't know
anything
we have math that proves it's equal and
logic that proves it isn't we have such
a strong tendency toward equal
probability that when logic tells us
we've got an exception to a normal 50 50
rule it
shocks us into taking it too seriously
it messes with our uniformity belief
enough to make us trust it martin
gardner wrote that krachik was no help
about logic in the wallet paradox
gartner couldn't explain it either all
these papers by very smart
mathematicians get into the math but
just discard the very real logical
objection
often by concluding with something along
the lines of
uh
don't play this game
no one can explain why without making a
few assumptions
maybe the wallet game is just an
antinomical paradox that we have to live
with but the coin flips and kittens
that's the type of math that can mislead
you
probability just isn't frequency and
frequency
is reality
so
life may be a series of 50 50s wins and
losses yeses
and no's
that lead us all to wildly different
outcomes
like
sitting at a whiteboard table with 64
kittens and
a pink leopard print wallet
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
you